hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer finally the red
band trailer for Sin City dos a dame to
kill for it's been a while since I've
done trailer reactions by myself it's
kind of weird I'm I used to having
someone with me
I'm excited to watch this why talk
anymore talked plenty about it on the
previous trailers let's stop talking
talking stops now no more talking no
anticipation thoughts talking must
commence into the after zone of silence
yes there we go three minutes and 19
seconds of pure awesomeness so [ __ ]
stoked to see this
it's rotten town it serves everybody
touches their arias
let's run down
soils everybody staring me up from which
I love you what I gotta do somebody's
gonna win
yeah did your help he's going up against
a lot of guns
pay the death
this won't take you thought sweetheart
is gonna take me in the moon
god yeah man they really amplified the
action I'm just so excited for this
movie like it's ridiculous how excited I
am
it looks different I mean the the tone
being established in the trailers feels
different you know like this one seems
like it might have a little bit more of
a fun vibe about it and something where
the and the action looks a little bit
crazier looks little bit more outlandish
I mean don't get me wrong it looks good
still and it seems like they have a more
solid storyline as opposed to having
multiple different stories and they
minorly connect and this one it seems
like these stories are really connecting
very well I hope it's good you know I
have some worries not because I've seen
something to get me worried it's just
it's a sequel I've been waiting for for
like [ __ ] ever so the fact that like
it's finally coming out and my worry is
that I just wanted to be good you know I
just want to be a great time [ __ ] man if
you haven't seen Sin City you gotta
watch it with the lights off that we can
get immersed in the black and white with
very little color experience that's
what's gonna make the theater experience
so awesome and Jessica Alba still gets
me horny to this day would love to [ __ ]
her Jessica's my cousin's name so I
color by a different name maybe I would
call her Patrice Patrice Konig that's
what I'll call her anyway guys if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe
right here thank you for subscribing if
you haven't subscribed why gonna do some
shout outs here own I Jack Daniels hey
did I get a shout out you have so many
videos I can't keep up but you can
always give me another one just in case
and this time I might catch it zero nine
Jack Daniels I don't believe I gave you
a shout out to good old Jack Daniels huh
this soda that's a good soda mmm-hmm
I know my drinks well yeah this is your
shout out jack jack is a good name
and a lot of movie characters are named
Jack I don't need too many people or
actually named Jack you know except for
my penis jackoff writer there is a vein
McGill for the lady I call my penis a
lady
Timothy Williams what happened to my
shout out I'm gonna cry now Timothy
you're getting your shout out here you
don't need a cry son listen everything's
gonna be okay Timothy I want you to know
that I'll always be there for you no
matter what happens no matter what okay
I will always be there for you Malik
Neff please give me a shout-out you are
awesome thanks man I know I'm awesome
tell me something I don't know awesome
sexy attractive in every possible way
cute bubbly fun great ass nice pecs
okay biceps hung like a donkey's tail
it's a compliment to myself but Malik
this is about you not about me and my
horse [ __ ] Malik man you make me smile
from cheek to cheek I think about you
and I just reek a whole new heaven I
think about this stuff and you're my
lucky number seven
I want to do this [ __ ] and guess what
man you've been forgiven you've been
forgiven for seeing it simple compliment
but that [ __ ] you really did meant and
that stuff happens right here and you'd
be heaven sent because you subscribe to
my channel
well welcome to the panel here we go
here we go here we go you want to do
this when I'm going off the rails
thinking about you Malik and I want to
kiss you from cheek to cheek and I want
you to sneak a peek at my little tiny
dick illegal leak I'm referring to my
penis that's what my dick illegaly cos
yeah